football d'abord hidalgo a mis sur pied
une équipe de france très jeune pour
rencontrer ce soir la tchécoslovaquie
une équipe de france sans les stéphanois
dont le calendrier est décidément trop
chargé en ce moment pour qu'on puisse se
permettre de les priver de leur étoile
les stéphanois avec l'équipe de france
avec cinq nouveaux contre la
tchécoslovaquie sur le premier acte
d'une pièce dont la trame est bien la
qualification de l'équipe de france de
football pour la coupe du monde 1978 en
espérant mieux encore privés de tous les
stéphanois retenus il est vrai pour
d'autres tâches hidalgo a misé sur
l'avenir en incorporant cinq jeunes
joueurs et parmi ces nouveaux on
attendra beaucoup ce soir de celui dont
on parle le plus depuis des mois michel
platini 20 ans promis à un bel avenir et
qui fera ses grands débuts en équipe
nationale j'ai un peu d'appréhension
mais je pense que c'est tout à fait
naturel mais non je pense pas je crois
que je vais m'en sortir et la débauche
d'époque vous faites pas ce que vous
jouable dans toutes les équipes il ya
deux jours vous avez joué avec l'armée
france l'armée au lavis contre la
roumanie d'un match difficile
les palois que ce soit préjudiciable à
votre rendement de l'un sur l'autre
non je pense pas parce que du coup de
début de saison en habitué par m a joué
deux matches par semaine
là ça va être un beau un peu plus dur
mais je crois que ça va être trop
difficile pour moi
un autre joueur fera ses grands débuts
internationaux aux postes clés d'avant
centre le sochalien robert pintenat sera
peut-être celui que stefan kovacs a
vainement cherché durant ses trois
années passées à la tête de l'équipe de
france
aujourd'hui michel hidalgo se trouve
confronté au même problème trouver
l'homme capable de faire pression sur la
défense adverse et surtout concrétiser
en buts les occasions fait nul doute en
tout cas que robert pintenat fera ce
soir tout son possible pour devenir un
titulaire à part entière de l'équipe de
france c'est une grande chance qui m'est
offert dix ans justine la saisir au
maximum donc je n'appréhende pas du tout
le match je prends le match
disons que c'était un match de
championnat et puis avec mon ami solaire
on va essayer de battre la défense chez
pascal faut jouer les matches comme ils
se présentent sans faire de sans dire
que c'est trop dur que c'est pas assez
dur fall tous les maçons sont difficiles
et puis c'est pas en équipe de france
que ça sera le plus facile donc
les matches mon avis faut les prendre
comme une vielle et sans se poser de
questions
une page nouvelle s'ouvre donc ce soir
pour l'équipe de france et pour son
entraîneur
souhaitons simplement et sans arrière
pensée à michel hidalgo de connaître des
joies égale à celle de robert herbin et
de ces stéphanois